what I love most about being up here is
simply being immersed in nature everyday
and being able to share that with the
students the biological station is
unique and that it gives students an
opportunity not to just merely learn
things up here I can showcase and
demonstrate the natural world biological
phenomena and gives students a real
experience and field biology the primary
course that I teach every summer is
general ecology which is an introductory
lecture based course with as little
lecture as possible we'll have a 3-hour
lecture and then we'll go out into the
field and do a variety of lab activities
anything from setting nets trap Nets out
on the lake to Lou Gill studies we've
gone rafting down rivers you read about
a lot of things in a biology textbook
but to actually be out in the field and
doing these things the research element
is so much more real one of the big
advantages to Hillsdale College
throughout its curriculum is that we
have a lot of the opportunities toys and
things that big schools have and unlike
a lot of big schools our students
actually get to use them for research
students get their own project I'm
looking at the population density of the
read-back salamanders I chose to do
research here because I enjoy being
outside and working with live animals
instead of in a lab we're basically
catching a whole bunch of them and
microchipping them and collecting data
because nobody's really study these
salamanders before kind of a new project
for Hillsdale College I've had students
invent new field equipment new field
techniques it's a very real opportunity
for students to go out and see what
ecologists do not merely learn about it
in a class
you
[Music]